so first let's see how we can set up
these data sets and how we can set up
this data analysis and this lesson
actually focuses on where this data
comes from and what do we need to do to
get these short read sequencing data and
put and use these short read sequencing
data to uh
to arrive at the taxonomic table and Etc
etcetera so that is what this one
focuses on first primarily in this uh
in in these steps to download data and
once you have obtained at this table we
can actually perform this uh Downstream
analysis of this
um using data to Pipeline and we can set
up these analysis in in the server also
and this and our part of this data or
curated portion of this data is included
as a demo pipeline in the server the
bioinfo server let this complete loading
and it can be accessed under these
amplicon 16s or 18 is sequencing in the
metagenomics section so if you have
login credentials to server keyboard
info server irrespective of your
subscription pattern or subscription
model you can access all of their demo
pythons and this demo pipeline can be
accessed by these using these drop down
button or clicking option and in this we
can see uh
I think it's in the red syndrome is here
yeah that's information time but um I
will I will generally show you how to uh
set up a data to pipeline not for the
red syndrome but for the different
projects so we start with the analysis
part and the input files are actually
um already uploaded and we have you can
access them from here and once you start
we actually perform some quality control
for our files
and then we
count them or user
and data to processes to count to merge
and to Cluster these
Portugues that's what we will do and
once this has been done we can actually
remove
um more than one otu clustered as or one
type of otus clustered into one cluster
that are chimeras and we can then use
these otu sequences to
explore the silver database or any other
database to assign tax form then we can
use
[Music]
neighbor joining algorithm to develop
phylogenetics of these otus which is one
of the key ah
steps in understanding or in ah
exploring or characterizing the
diversity of these otus or the samples
then we can perform data visualization
then we can end the pipeline so once you
build this pipeline for the analysis and
in any method data to our time to you
will get access to all the output files
that you can download and you can
visualize and you can explore and what
to explore and what to perform and what
are the analysis to focus what are the
results to be
identified and implicated can be
thoroughly
awesome
read and understood from the associated
resources that we are linking to during
each and every session of the program so
I want to show you some of the
visualization that we actually show and
this is the abundance plot that you will
often see or often notice in microbiome
or metagenomics related publication
I think we should yes exactly yeah and
we this is an interactive abundance plot
we can quickly check which tax of
bacteria is this does this specific
section
and we see some uh difference in the
abundance level of this bacterial
idities for different samples that can
be related to their biological condition
or phenotypical version now this
specific plot which is not proportional
plot which is raw abundance plot and the
relative abundance relative proportional
abundance plot can be used to understand
uh the proportional abundance of several
different microbial population
or different samples
so this project also I think gives you
option two
um
guys to run the pipeline I think in the
yes it gives the same result same uh
discusses the same thing here here is
where you can actually access the
pipeline that we are we actually set up
for the lesson that we focuses on focus
on right it's the same data to pipeline
but for the uh
oh
it's not for the rich don't know it's
first different pipelines okay
so uh I wanted to
show you that this proportional plot
will help us uh
clear some of the hypothesis that we
generally develop once in the
non-proportional or absolute abundance
plot now if we see this level of the
bacteria identities in these three
samples they are absolutely identical
because it is being scaled up or it has
been normalized across the different
samples that's what I wanted to show you
so these uh
interactive visualization will help
abundance level of our abundance level
of microbial Community from our sample
and in order to perform more uh specific
analysis that we will also uh briefly
and then we run like r or python to uh
to perform that analysis go to the
server and that can be accessed again as
a demo pipeline under the kind section
of the metagenomics uh ah part right in
this time we see that the red syndrome
project is here we can go and set up
this analysis quickly
so kaim adds some more uh
steps to process and pre-process the
data and post process the data into
chime objects before applying data to
pipeline into that or data to analysis
into the into our data right
and it does it performs all the steps
that we do in the data tool
but it gives us some more options or
more options to perform some quality
visualization
since this is done
the details for these steps are all
included in the associated Publications
not publication and associative
resources
go
so when you sign up for this program you
will get access to uh
okay what happened here
can you see my screen it's a little bit
yes sir the screen is visible just it's
black
Ed out right yeah for some reasons it is
yeah for some reason it is okay let me
start over again in order to access that
a dashboard or
analyzing this data or changing the key
parameters of this data uh during
visualization process so that we can
perform this analysis without
[Music]
um
re-running the pipeline or without any
without resorting to any code based
methods which we will also explore
option is available for kind and for
most of the pipelines that you are going
to set up in the talk about bioinfo
server
so the process involves in selecting the
next available or choosing one of the
next available
analysis options that are highlighted
when you select the previous ones so
since this is a demo pipeline it's only
act letting me select the path with
which we have set up the pipeline and in
reality when you select or when you opt
for this analysis methods when you
select one of these uh options are all
algorithms then it's going to give you
all the uh it's going to highlight all
possible route that you can take so why
should I say that you can design your
analysis methods or sequences depending
upon the data depending upon the
hypothesis that you are actually testing
so this external dashboard will give you
options like
let it load
uh
options like changing the taxonomic
level of your relative abundance plot
right so in the interactive
visualization plot the taxonomic level
is fixed once we have when we are
running the pipeline or when we are
accessing the pipeline setting up the
pipeline here you can change that from
the family level you can change that to
phylum level and
explore their informative uh level of
informativeness right and look at this
the final level is not very informative
because it is most of them are actually
populated by vermicutes and the best
level at which we can study this is not
the genus or family genus could be too
varied
and it can have several of the not
applicable uh
or unknown resources in them for example
unknown or uncultured organisms or other
organisms here as grouped by these
purple cases right they are all other
which are unclassified a Genus so uh one
level
uh related to uh
red syndrome or not from the disease
there is the host disease
yes here and then it is going to update
by itself
and then you can explore for them for
their uh separation for that
distribution so again in the diversity
plot we can check uh different
categories of different annotations of
your of your samples here I'm focused I
am focused on red syndrome you can also
change this up by selecting for example
body mass index body mass index etc etc
that we want to select so this dashboard
gives you freedom and flexibility to
change The annotation to change the
grouping level and to change the
display of the of the associated plots
that
that are not possible in the
um in the interactive platform Orbiter
that are very helpful when you are
opting for when when we want to
understand metagenomics data analysis
using a code free option and this can
also be performed using r as a
um
tool for analysis and that is actually
given in the in this project 13 which is
uh
um which explores the role of high fat
diet and obesity using model system like
Mouse right and when we go back to my uh
keynote let's say
can you see my screen
so it's loading it's not visible yet yes
yes and now it's good yeah right the
user helpful uh the uh the advantage of
using a model system to understand
microbial the effect of microbial
immunity and their abundance level on
several different uh aspects is actually
that we can use
um specific antibiotics to completely
reduce or completely nullify the
existing bacterial node in the model
system which is not possible for human
samples so we can take a mouse model for
example and then completely devoid that
Mouse model for uh for any trace of
microbial community in their gut and
then load them up with a specific
we can process at the end of
observation process and quantify the
abundance level that is what is actually
done in this specific project so they
take the mouse samples and for
completely cleaned up Mouse they give
the Mouse
um microbial community that is developed
or that is built or that is actually uh
um yeah developed for different mouse
that takes Hypha diet and for another
mouse microbial
samples from micro samples from another
mouse that take normal attack so and the
behavioral changes for mouse that
received microbial transplantation
Community transplantation from high fat
diet fat mouse and compared to the
microbial
transplantation or transplanted mouse
that received transplantation from a
normal diet Mouse and their behavioral
differences are actually studied after
given number of time and that are
actually explored in this specific
project so
it's on
this Downstream analysis which takes the
tables or which takes uh the abundance
table which takes the taxonomic table
under which also takes a sample
sample annotation and then we can
perform Downstream analysis using R and
using a package that we will definitely
explore during the program but um
and where usage in using phyrocity
package right in this phytosic package
we can we can bundle up this abundance
table and this uh this taxonomic
information and this annotation
information into one object and this one
object is what is being repeatedly being
used to study for example uh
uh to measure the diversity across
different sample or across groups of
samples in terms of alpha diversity or
in terms of beta diversity that can also
be studied
right uh yeah this is uh this is simply
the
um
nmds plot to show their differences
using Bray distance methods and some
more phylogeny based distance methods
like unifrag and these ones are also
explored and given a detailed account of
how to perform this analysis you see r
as a tool for performing this analysis
this gives you lot of flexibility in
terms of the number of samples to
analyze in terms of what are the
distance methods that you can choose to
analyze
visualization options like PCO a n and
DS or
umap to use to visualize your samples so
um and it also gives you a lot of
freedom in in terms of grouping of
samples according to phylaxing them and
Etc or you can also for example
restrict your analysis to top 25 otus or
top 50 depending upon their abundance
levels or depending upon their diversity
levels in this case so that can also be
studied so this R is a tool for
Downstream analysis gives you all the
codes for performing this analysis and
it also gives you a portion where you
can try your knowledge of Performing
this analysis from the previous true
resources right it gives you or this
console is a is a is an R console that
is loaded at the back end and we can
perform all the analysis given in these
measures of diversity are given in these
sections I use these to perform the
analysis and we have given you small uh
um
assignments some some challenges when
these challenges can be accessed from
lesson six this is a continuation of
lesson six so we go back to lesson six
quickly
which focuses on how to set up these
Downstream analysis in pilotic
environment
down down
yes in uh try it yourself section so we
give options or we give links to the
input table and then we actually leave
out some of the key portions of the
Syntax for example here this is left out
free a left out incomplete so that you
can refer or you can base on your
understanding of how this is performed
complete this analysis in this console
and gain
good feedback for your own understanding
uh for this code based lessons so uh
similar analysis is also performed is
also
um possible in Python and more details
are actually available in other
Associated resources and also in we will
explore Python's option to perform this
analysis in the program also